[Música]
cada pacote do alto de mais de 30 na
aldeia tira da janela abaixo pato de
calvino ea sua gravata calvino não tem
tempo pra pensar está atrasado sátiras
também da janela com quem precisamos
ainda no ar alcança os sapatos primeiro
o direito a calça depois os kers no ar
enquanto caio tenta encontrar a melhor
posição para pintá los até casos com o
sapato esquerdo falou uma vez mas volta
a arte consegue olha para baixo já se vê
o chão
antes porém a gravata calvino está a
cabeça para baixo com o chão brusco a
sua mão direita apanha no ar e depois
com os seus dedos apressados mais
certeiros das voltas necessárias para o
nó da gravata está posta
os sapatos olha de novo para ele os
ataques dos deputados da último sair no
nó da gravata bem a tempo
é um momento chega ao chão em um carro
este é o primeiro sonho calvino uma
personagem e um livro com os alunos a
vasco vai acampar em a nota prévia esta
apresentação e criar a nota prévia à a a
minha vida a história da minha vida
o tema transversal com acho que só a
gente usar frio e conseguiu muito vai
cruzar a raiz ea a raiz do meu
pensamento o do cotai motivava inspirado
no meu trabalho profissional é é a
cidade são os lugares da cidade ea forma
como as pessoas nos habitats com elas
funcionam e as diferentes possibilidades
que uma cidade está e se multiplicar e
que se calhar faltou um novo vez mais na
frança de calvino mas não o personagem
emoção está vazio mas o autor e talvez
na sociedade invisíveis que nos
apresenta 55 possibilidades da cidade
que nos passa um enorme potencial não
dar um simbolismo e um enorme imaginário
que não têm vindo a
a insight curar ea pensar em relação com
a arte com as pessoas e com os
habitantes com ela que nelas habitam a
outro artista que muito me inspirei
muito inquieta que eu queria também que
trazer nesta introdução da minha
apresentação e com quem eu tenho tido
privilégio de trabalhar perto o time
está é uma s músico inglês crítica
função de um artista é inspirar a
cultura e que uma das melhores formas de
fazer é comprometendo as pessoas no
processo de criação resumo o que tem
orientado o meu trabalho tem sido
bastante esse triângulo da dos lugar
vacilar na sua relação com as pessoas e
artes no cruzamento de estudos
esta imagem foi minha filha conta deu
pra dizer que foi ela que fez 48 anos é
e eu apresento aqui para falar um
bocadinho 2012 como como com o frio e eu
fiz patram eu fiz parte de diferentes
fases da do que foi a capital europeia
da cultura em guimarães numa primeira
fase do pensamento mais uma vez por
torno à cidade as diferentes
possibilidades será o que é com um
evento desta natureza poderia
acrescentar a minha ademar mas depois
também o próprio a implementação do do
programa que me trouxe a
responsabilidade que fez com que eu com
que cruzasse com um conjunto de artistas
e programa 12 diferentes pensador nesta
área que me motivaram americano é
vontade de criar um gesto em nome
próprio
foi também o ano em que eu conheci o
amor da minha vida
ricardo que é a segunda metade do
projeto que vai apresentar provas que
iria que são os nossos representados
pela minha filha
tanto os dois depois os dois
trabalharmos na capital europeia da
cultura foi lá que nos conhecemos e
partilhávamos os dois este pensamento
enfim da arte do sentido do do sentido
artístico forma que a arte poderia
contribuir por exemplo para a democracia
o pensamento epatur ânsia para a
diversidade a trabalhar nas casas das
pessoas e criamos um projeto que chama
onda amarela e outra amarela é é uma uma
empresa que se dedica ao que se inspira
nos lugares das pessoas para criar
projetos artísticos e educativos e
sociais e suja
em resposta a esta o contato
partilhávamos os dois em 2012 mas também
em resposta a um conjunto do convite
para pensar nos ano património e de que
forma é que poderia nos valores algo
pensar em territórios pensar em
populações e comunidades e como é que a
atriz poderia valorizar sempre de forma
colaborativa que essa que acreditar no
chez há há há há certa
se calhar importa é que explicar se que
mais objectivamente o que fazemos estes
projectos artísticos sociais e
educativos podem se materializar nos
diferentes formas
o espetáculo musical mas também o vídeo
um filme ou uma visita uma conversa ou
uma publicação a diferentes formatos
trabalham em diferentes formatos
trabalhamos muito na música porque
optaram por é músico e também é aquele
ar mais formais enviado conseguiram ser
uma relação com uma combinado com as
pessoas que habitualmente não são o que
não são artistas mas antes falar dessas
diferentes tipologias falar nos
processos de trabalho esta imagem é o
resultado de uma conversa tida no
momento de reflexão a meio de um projeto
que fizemos escrevo uma noção extensa
mais de um ano e os processos para
conseguirmos esses resultados que falei
há pouco os espetáculos ou do filme
outras publicações das conversas
os processos são sempre mais ou menos
preciso criar um espaço de partilha é o
criamos a possibilidade de qualquer
pessoa qualquer pessoa mesmo em
colaboração em contato com um conjunto
de artistas que ser levado nesta
trabalho
cruzem e partilhem rotinas idéias
problemas foi a hungria
enfim seja trabalhar sejam elas no
centro da criação artística portanto
desafio é criar o objeto tiff artístico
conteúdo é sempre a partir do que as
pessoas trazem para os processos de
trabalho e uma amarela por isso e porque
funciona muito perto com tanta gente com
muitas vezes não fazem de imediato parte
do nosso círculo da das pessoas muitas
vezes está aqui a pensar nos números à
parte das vezes tá tá no lado mais
emocional e ficarem porta também aqui
apresentar o que é sexo trabalho
processo da criação artística
colaborativa permitem coisas muito
bonitas que aconteçam coisas muito
bonitas que é isto é dentro em cima no
mesmo palco o encontro de pessoas que de
outra forma o que eles não conseguiriam
não se cruzariam ea um carinho isso que
está a acontecer hoje aqui acho eu com
certeza que se não fosse a propósito do
tgv que não teria conhecido a estas
pessoas todas nem a história da sua vida
eis que tentar fazer é a comunidade
o centro é o sentimento de nós é uma das
coisas mais bonitas que olhar para esta
palavra é que vou passar por criar
alguns projetos que tem sido a objetos
de trabalho e criação da amarela e este
projeto aconteceu em bragança e foi o
primeiro projeto na mala foi muito
importante para nós foi um longo projeto
mais de um ano e que tenham lá todo um
programa dentro de altinha apresentações
de grande escala com uma orquestra
comunitária e jirak pelo times time mas
com a participação de pessoas
provenientes do
vários lugares desta cidade e outras
duas vezes o conservatório até ao início
da terceira idade por exemplo mas também
música profissionais e pessoas que
individualmente se juntaram a nós mas
foi um programa que teve também um
conjunto de outras atividades como
oficinas workshops peças artísticas
para ele as conversas de conversa girou
e de contos numa zona fronteiriça das
aldeias raianas portugal numa partilha
de memórias e histórias aqui é um outro
exemplo é um projeto que não ocorre o
ano inteiro mas ocorre todos os anos há
mais cinco anos chama só questões da
vida airada e acontecem em ílhavo no
festival rádio fonekha e aqui o desafio
é sempre tudo porque acontece já há
cinco anos a fio encontrar sempre um
tema novo que seja identificativo destas
pessoas que ligava uma coisa essas
pessoas que essas pessoas estavam também
informações sobre ela e que consiga se
consiga montar um espetáculo sempre a
que entusiasmo aí que o surpreenda o
público este ano
a propósito deste projecto também
conseguimos finalmente publicar um livro
onde fizemos um uma reflexão do que este
trabalho e também gravar um desktop como
é um projeto que já tem cinco anos
permite nos fazer dar um gás tóxico das
melhores músicas criadas no âmbito da
carta da virada
continua a ser a casa da virada mas aqui
essa imagem é pra falar em cada um desta
nossa vontade e intenção de que todos os
grandes projetos tenham sempre em
consideração a participação ainda que
pontual do público tanto o público pode
fazer parte do bope no nac algum momento
senti sua parte daquela comunidade
fantasia criada a lei
há também outros projetos que são só não
resultou em nada material são de
aproximação à populações neste caso
populações ou lugar
muitos povoados é o caso das aldeias
históricas de portugal nas pernas geral
primeira baixa
o projeto de comunicação do programa
maior que é uma farra
os canais que acontece todos os anos em
aveiro e com músicos da cilada com um
único programa do festival
atala outra camada que falava atrás de
um novo olhar sobre o mesmo território
ou mesmo lugar numa visita a uma cidade
além da dimensão científica apresentar
sempre essa dimensão vivencial de alguém
que com neste caso por exemplo era o
castelo no gasóleo e estes dois mil anos
e manuel brandão natália
tenho muitas histórias da sua infância
de terem brincava naquela castelo na
castello e partilharam conosco neste dia
para um arquivo que fez a visita mais
científica em rigorosa do objeto as suas
memórias emanuel no final de forma
bastante emocionada partilhou connosco
que achava que morria antes subir a cor
do seu castelo porque enquanto criança
nunca teve coragem audácia dos seus
colegas do trio paz
até lá a cima com medo de cair e agora
percebeu que existe já uma escada mas o
castelão estará fechado e pôs a
propósito desta visita com seguida essa
é feito mais um exemplo aqui em
guimarães a partir da casa da memória
pac também lascada está
a intenção ea vontade de acrescentar
novas leituras a história mas também no
formato do objeto de uma direção neste
caso nós desenvolvemos 11 jogo
a propósito do programa cujo objetivo
era a audição do patrimônio material do
verificado no número de classificados do
norte de portugal e esse jogo funcionou
como um objeto aqui da relação com os
mais jovens
e aqui é um momento propondo um conjunto
de atividades jurídicas - a volvo filhas
para dessa forma se relacionarem com um
monumento que este caso é que foi muito
especial para nós
foi a primeira vez que trabalhamos com
uma comunidade de surdos e aqui o
desafio era criar mais um projeto
musical e foi próprio para o festival
que muito admirava mas já tínhamos
visitado como espectador do tumor nos
açores é um o futebol muito particular
muito especial e que nos desafiou para
no dia para uma semana sem a incidência
criarmos com a cessão do sul de são
miguel
juntamente com alguns músicos locais e
as intérpretes a 11 a produção de um
novo espetáculo foi um desafio
primitivos aprender imenso sobre essa
combinar as suas dificuldades acho tudo
nas suas capacidades e ea fim e foi um
gesto que marcou depois desta dimensão
do que tudo pra como tudo que acontece
pra lá do dado momento da apresentação
os ensaios sul as relações que criam as
partilhas as paixões suas vidas como não
temos muitos exemplos de vidas que se
alteram o que ocultam um novo dado pelo
contato com este ano do projeto contato
com a experiência de criar e com isso
pensa por ao ganharem coragem para
assumir
há um rumo diferente na na vida
depois projetos grande escala e acho que
foi para a celebração do dia da europa
portanto aqui a intenção era furarmos a
diversidade cultural com a participação
de diferentes nacionalidades diferentes
culturas aconteceu em malta que na
altura era o país que estava a correr a
comissão européia ea dimensão do
pensamento que é traz altos este
projecto o questionário no chão para que
servem as coisas para que serve cada um
destas processos e para quem quiser
neste caso o projeto abre esta província
escala conclusões em conjunto sempre
forma colaborativa incessantes e em
jeito assim de final a mensagem de que
eu estava de partilhar convosco que são
crianças minhas e do ricardo na amarela
que é através da arte e da cultura que
grande parte dos problemas espanha no
seu disco tem esse trabalho neste
projeto nós tentamos fazer sempre isso e
quando tínhamos com toda a gente não é
quando o toda a gente possa efetivamente
fazer parte deixam sempre diversas
diferenças e camadas de informação
dentro das nossas cabeças e os
preconceitos são ultrapassados a novas
perspectivas de vida a portas que se
abrem e porque mais requisitados também
que a criação dessas novas abordagens
aos lugares ea sua cultura e voltem lá
atrás
arraes o meu pensamento assim como a
função da participação efetiva das
populações nas atividades artísticas são
chave da produção e disseminação do
conhecimento e reflexão tão essenciais à
democracia e apresentar o essencial aos
tempos de hoje e fazendo preparando este
está a apresentação e olhando pra rir
prática isso quer o tema transversal de
ter é que encontrei essa imagem que
fizemos no ano passado numa num numa
reflexão do prodec tínhamos andado em
2017 inovava as uma das postagens
alguma raiz mas no sentido mais braços
craques que nem eles vão ramificando e
vão tocando em diferentes lugares em
diferentes pessoas e e esta é vaz serra
isso nosso trabalho
tinha paixão e agora quer terminar com o
brasil como o responsável por editar
campo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
eu acho que o tempo abrir voltar por
cima
eu vou cantar